costumes and glitter and eyelashes this
is nothing new this is you and your
element this is you in your element
reaction after getting on this on the
stage for the first time honestly I had
so much fun out there and I'm critical
in myself so I already had my notes but
I had fun and then hearing the judges
reactions was of course it wasn't you
know tough but that's okay it's just
notes to get better and I knew this was
day one and I want to grow more and more
from here so I'm taking it in and I had
a good time a problem with the
performance was all the Beyonce stuff
we've you hear Hamlin said that the
Beyonce stuff how old is he the first
thing she does when she came down was a
traditional cha-cha step so I'm like
what are we looking at here Beyonce stop
what is it you wish Len Beyonce's in
right now right I know you're a big fan
of Dancing with the Stars so what does
it feel to be here in the new and
improved ballroom and like wearing your
sparkly outfit and doing it it is so
surreal honestly I'm a super fan so I
watch the show growing up with my mom I
have some really nice memories watching
with her I'm invested with all the
contestants and their stories and of
course the glitz and glamour and the
dances it's all incredible so to be a
part of it now I'm fangirling like I'm
like pinch to me I can't believe I'm
here is there any chance that you will
perform one of your new solo songs on
dancer the Stars who knows I think there
might be a really great chance of that
we can do anything yeah I can do
anything
Sean Spicer can wear that shirt y'all
can do anything exactly man thank you
[Music]